Dave Rubin is the house to the ribbon
report he's now in his written testimony
Michael schellenberger said that recent
reporting of lawsuits have revealed Dave
quote a large and growing network of
government agencies academic
institutions and non-governmental
organizations that are actively
censoring American citizens often
without their knowledge on a range of
issues including on the origins of covid
coveted vaccines emails related to
Hunter Biden's business dealings climate
change renewable energy fossil fuels and
many many other issues he and mataibi
refer to it as the censorship industrial
complex and it's frightening
John what people really need to
understand about this beyond what taibi
and schellenberger are laying out and I
happen to know shaolenberger personally
this is a good guy these guys are
liberals they are lefties I would go out
on a limb I can't swear to this but I'm
pretty sure that neither one of them
have ever voted for a Republican and
certainly don't consider themselves
right-leaning or conservative or
anything like that so you know a lot of
their motives have been impugned by
several members of Congress today and
it's really shameful and embarrassing as
for the content that they're talking
about I wish this was surprising but
those of us who have been paying
attention to this for a couple years now
we all sort of knew that something was
going on here and now we're finding out
basically that our worst fears have
become true and I think you know John I
was up at Twitter a couple weeks ago
with Elon we met for a few hours and I
met a few of the engineers there and
after I met with Elon at the end of the
meeting there was no intention there
that I was going to release any
information or anything I said to him
quite honestly I said hey do you mind
mind if I tell people what I saw here
today and his exact words without
hesitating were as long as it's true so
the idea that this guy has a political
bent or is somehow manipulating
information or manipulating the the
reporters the legitimate journalists who
are showing up there is just crazy and I
think we're still just at the beginning
of pulling the string on this thing and
we're probably going to find out way
more the question always is though you
know is anything going to happen because
of it that I don't know yeah but that
that meeting May put you in the
crosshairs of the Federal Trade
Commission which wants information from
Twitter on which journalists it
discussed the Twitter files with and
what the nature of the information
exchange was which might seem to run up
against the First Amendment there I'm
not sure but I think it gets close
well look if you have the government
pressuring a private organization to
censor free speech that is as close as
you can get to a violation of the First
Amendment short of the government doing
it uh itself now the question really is
and I've spoken to a couple First
Amendment lawyers on this you know you
as a private citizen you don't have much
recourse against the government it's not
as if they're going to suddenly pay you
out oh we're sorry we stepped on your
first amendment rights here's a million
bucks I mean you might get a letter
saying we're sorry about it something
like that but in essence what we really
need now more than apologies or
penalties or anything else is just for
some honesty from the government and
just say we are not going to do this
anymore because as taibi pointed out
most of what was accused of being
misinformation often turned out to be
true whether it was reporting on Hunter
Biden's laptop or whether it was covid
related vaccine related mandate related
uh you know Russia collusion Etc so and
also not all of it was done by
journalists I don't consider myself a
journalist I tell people what I think
think for a living people can agree or
disagree but the average citizen who is
out there on Twitter sharing information
that's what we all thought the promise
of social media was and unfortunately it
became something much more nefarious I
just want to finish this off don't need
an answer but I wanted to put this up
this is from schellenberger's written
testimony call for number three here in
terms of who gets suspended you don't
have to represent a threat anymore he
says quote the government no longer
needs a predicate of calling you a
terrorist or an extremist to deploy
government resources to counter your
political activity the only predicate it
needs is simply the assertion that the
opinion you expressed on social media
is wrong
Dave always good to catch up with you
thanks for joining us appreciate it
John that's why I don't stand by any of
my opinions anything I've said here has
nothing to do with Dave Rubin don't
worry about that you fold like a cheap
suit I love it thanks dude if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell